hi today I'd like to talk to you about
circuits last time we finished up the LT
is and signals and systems where we
learned how to both model existing
systems and predict their long-term
behavior but we haven't forayed into how
to actually create systems in the
physical world right we've created some
amount of systems in software and made
some brains for our robots but if we
want to make something in the physical
world then we probably have to come up
with ways to model physical systems or
use physical components that starts our
new module on circuits circuits are
going to be our first foray into
designing systems in the physical world
also designing systems using physical
components it's worth mentioning now
that the information that you learn
about circuits is not is good for more
things than even circuits you can use
basic circuit diagrams and properties of
circuits to model all sorts of kinds of
systems especially ones in the human
body right circulatory system
neurological system different kinds of
fluid flow that kind of thing in the
next few videos we'll go over how to
represent circuits and also cover some
of the basic methods by which people
solve circuits will also introduce an
element called an op-amp and use that
element in order to enable us to do
things like modularity an abstraction
from our circuits first let's talk about
representation and the general sense
when you come across a circuit diagram
you're going to see at the very broad
level a bunch of elements and a bunch of
connections between the elements those
things will form loops and nodes if you
don't actually specify the elements then
your cert a gram actually looks a whole
lot like a block diagram and in fact
block diagrams and circuit diagrams are
very closely related in part because
block diagrams are used to model
feedback systems which frequently are
implemented using circuits
in this course we're going to be
focusing on independent sources and
resistors as the two major kinds of
elements that we'll use in our circuits
we'll also use things like
potentiometers which are resistors that
you can adjust and op amps and we'll
look at op amps specifically in a later
video but I have one drawn up here just
so you recognize it when you see it
written note that it looks a whole lot
like the block diagram symbol for a game
and that's intentional and we'll cover
that later but in the meantime the other
sources that we're going to be using are
independent current and voltage sources
we're going to use resistors to adjust
the amount of voltage and current that
we're actually dealing with and then
sample either the current or the voltage
at a particular point in our circuit to
get the desired values that we're after
on a circuit diagram when you're
interested in the voltage drop across a
particular element you'll indicate it by
putting a plus and minus sign this also
indicates the directionality of the
voltage drop likewise when you're
interested in the current flowing
through a particular element you'll
usually see an indication of it by
labeling the current I and then maybe I
was some sort of subscript and an arrow
indicating the direction of current flow
through that element so that you know
you avoid making sign errors with the
person that might be reading or writing
your diagram a quick note here this is
the reason that electrical engineers use
J to symbolize values in the complex
plane it's because I is used in
particular for values of current
let's review Kirchhoff's voltage law and
Kirchhoff's current laws you've probably
covered this in 802 electricity and
magnetism or possibly an AP physics
class but we're gonna go over it really
fast right now Kirchhoff's voltage law
is that the voltage drop around a loop
is equal to zero or if you take the
voltage drop across a particular loop in
your sub search in your circuit the some
of those voltage drops is going to be
zero let's demonstrate on this diagram
or all demonstrate on this diagram say
the voltage drop across this element is
equal to V right it doesn't matter what
it is we're gonna stick with that the
voltage drop across these elements if I
were to move around this loop is going
to sum to zero note that when I move
through note that if I'm tracing out my
voltage drop across this loop I'm
actually moving through this voltage
source in the direction opposite of its
indicated potential so when I move
through this voltage source I'm going to
account for its value as negative V as I
work my way around the rest of the
circuit the voltage drop across these
elements is going to sum to V this is
true for all notes all loops in my
circuit so any loop that includes V the
elements ia counter has a consequence of
moving around that loop
are going to have voltage drop equal and
opposite to the value I get by moving
through V in this direction this loop
counts too but it doesn't include V all
this loops tells me is that the voltage
drop across this element is equivalent
to the voltage drop across this element
or the voltage drop in this direction
across that element is equal to the
voltage drop in this direction across
that up across this element that's
Kirchhoff's voltage law Kirchhoff's
current law is that the current flow
into a particular node is equal to the 0
or all the if you take all of the
current flows in and out of a particular
node and sum them they should sum to
zero I've actually got the same set up
here I'm not going to use a current
divider
I'm interested in the current flowing
over this element it's actually the same
as the current flowing over this element
because resistance doesn't change
current or resistors flowing through a
resistor should not change the grade so
this is still the same I here's my node
the current flowing in this direction
and in this direction if I took the
linear combination of these two currents
they would be equal in value to the
current flowing into this node
what I'm looking at the current flowing
through a particular node I pick a
direction it's usually arbitrary I pick
a direction it's arbitrary which
direction I pick typically you pick
currents flowing into the node as being
positive i sum of all the currents and I
set that equal to zero so in this case
or
pretty simple
let's practice on this particular
circuit one thing to note is that when
you're solving circuits in the general
sense both when you want ta help and
when you're solving for a midterm and
want partial credit you want to label
all of your nodes all of your elements
and all of the currents that you're
interested in solving see I've got my
voltage drop across this resistor this
resistor and this resistor labeled as
well as these currents which I'll also
be solving for the first thing that I
would do when approaching this problem
is attempt to reduce this circuit to
something that is a little bit simpler
the first thing that I'm gonna do is try
to figure out how to change these two
resistors in parallel into a single
resistor and still have an equivalent
circuit that'll allow me to solve for I
1 because there'll be zero nodes in my
system I'll just have one single loop
and the current through this system will
just be the over R so if I'm just
looking at these two resistors I have
resistors in parallel in the general
sense the way to solve for resistors in
parallel is take the inverse
of the some of their inverses
when you only have two resistors you can
typically cheat by saying that this is
equal to their product over their sum
I'm going to redraw my current
understanding of the circuit
the other step that I've saved myself is
that because these resistors are in
parallel there are current divider they
take the current in and divide it two
ways determined by the ratio between
these two values
the thing I'm actually interested in
expressing is that V 2 and V 3 are the
same value when you have a current
divider the voltage drop across all
elements in the current divider are the
same so the value of V here is going to
be both V 2 and V 3
to our plus six fifths our I'm going to
go with 16 fifths are for now
I've sold fry
at this point I have a voltage divider
which means that the current flowing
through this part of the system is going
to be the same but the voltage drop and
the voltage drop across this element
versus this element is going to be
proportional to the ratio between these
two values
v1 is going to be the amount of the
total resistance in this simple circuit
that this resistor contributes over the
entire resistance in the system or 10 v
hour or 16 v star which is 10 sixteenths
R or 5/8 R or it's going to be 5/8 V
same thing happens with v2
note that these two values should sum to
be in order to maintain kirchoff's
voltage law we've also found v3 so the
two things that we have to left to find
are I 2 and I 3
here I've just done kirchoff's current
law for this node because I'm working
with a current divider I can break up
the total current flowing into that node
into the number of parts equal to the
sum of these values and then distribute
them and the method appropriate given
that less resistance means more current
what do I mean by that well I mean that
here my current is equal to 5/16 V over
R
I too is going to be equal to this value
over the sum of these two values times
i1 likewise and just to simplify
that concludes my tutorial on circuits
next time we'll talk about other ways we
can solve this circuit and then we'll
end up talking about albums